- We can't roll the credit
to that one last feel
good story to hopefully
bring you a little extra joy.
This is What I'm Liking.
It's Asian American and
Pacific Islander Heritage Month
here in the US.
And a group of artists in Atlanta have
collaborated to ensure kids know
about the profound contributions
the AAPI community has made to
American culture and history.
They put out a coloring book
called the ABCs of AAPIs
and it features an extensive collection
of influential figures.
We have the co-creative director
for the project on the line right now.
Everybody let's say hi to
Kavi watching on WSBTV!
Hi.
(audience applause)
- Hi Kelly.
It's so good to meet you.
- It's nice to meet you as well.
First of all, you look like
you're in a very cool place.
I like that brick wall with
all that little neon going on
looks like a cool bar or really cool pad.
So, so how did, how did the idea
for the coloring book come about?
- So I am a videographer
and creative consultant with
Asian American Advocacy Fund
and we were lucky enough
to get a grant to work
with Asian American artists in the
area to advance some social issue.
So we did a brainstorming session with
dozens of artists in Atlanta,
and we asked them basically what is it
that you wanted to make or see growing up?
And the AAPI community, we've been
through a lot these past two years.
So we wanted to make
something that was healing
and felt community driven,
but also celebratory
for our heritage and AAPI Heritage Month.
So we figured the ABCs
of AAPIs coloring book
would do just that.
And we engaged with different
student organizations to
research this huge list of
influential Asian figures.
And we wanted to also add experiences that
felt true to our culture.
- I love that.
So you've actually gotten support
from people featured in
the book as well, right?
- Absolutely. And it has felt so surreal
for that because K is for Michelle Kwan.
- Kwan, yeah.
- And I mean, I grew up
watching Michelle and, you know
feeling so represented
when she won the Olympics
and we tagged her in an Instagram story
and she responded and she was like,
can I, can I have a book?
And we're like, you can have
as many books as you want.
And there are poetry passages as well
to give context to the figures.
And we've gotten so much
community support as well.
So in fact there is 150 foot display
of our coloring book in all
color on the Atlanta belt line
which is this huge pedestrian friendly
and biker friendly pathway
all across the city.
And it's just so affirming
to see our art display
to thousands of people every day.
We hope that you'll come see it.
If you're in the area, it's
up until the end of June.
- It is such a beautiful way
to educate everyone on people.
Maybe they didn't know,
especially children seeing this.
It's such a really cool
innovative way to do this.
Way to go Kavi.
This is really cool.
I'm liking your post right now, alright?
- Oh my gosh.
- Alright and that's not all girl,
our season long partner,
Pilot Pen, makers of G2,
the go to pen of the Kelly Clarkson show.
They wanna honor ultimate
overachievers just like you ma'am.
So they're gonna be writing you a check
to the Asian American Advocacy Fund
on your behalf for a thousand dollars.
And... (audience applause)
And I'm also gonna add
5,000 dollars to that
for a total of 6,000 dollars because
we think what you're doing is really rad.
Thank you so much, Kavi!